[MUSIC PLAYING]
VALERIYA SHIN: Hi, everyone.
I'm Valeriya Shin, a customer
engineer at Google Cloud.
ERICA CHUONG: And I'm Erica
Chuong, a partner engineer
at Google Cloud.
Welcome back to another segment
of "Google Cloud Technical
Guides for Startups."
In this video, we'll be focusing
on Continuous Integration
and Continuous Deployment,
also known as CI/CD,
using Google Cloud.
In this episode,
we're going to cover,
what is CI/CD,
CI/CD in practice,
setting up CI/CD, as well as
a Google Cloud Console demo.
So without any
further ado, let's
get right into exploring the
Google Cloud platform together.
Continuous Integration,
or CI, is the process
of automating the building
and testing of changes
to code in order to
detect problems early.
Continuous Delivery,
or CD, is the process
of automating deployments
across multiple environments
in a safe, low-risk,
and quick manner.
Let's take a deeper
look into each.
CI-- again, Continuous
Integration--
is the process where
code changes undergo
a series of automated processes
to ensure that the application
or system is still working.
Part of the CI pipeline
may be to build or compile
an application once
the code changes have
been made in order to
validate and ensure that there
are no breaking changes.
This can be achieved through
a shared repository where
developers commit and merge code
that is then saved, reviewed,
and tested.
Additional steps could be
included and automated,
such as unit tests, integration
tests, and deployment
of the same artifact.
You should have some sort
of tool for source code
management, such as Cloud
Source Repositories, GitHub,
or Bitbucket.
You can also have a CI server
for building and testing code,
such as Cloud Build,
Jenkins, or circleCI.
With continuous delivery,
deploying artifacts
from your CI server
must be done manually.
With CD, or Continuous
Deployment, on the other hand,
this is the practice of
delivering new software
features through an
automated deployment process.
Usually right after CI, CD may
take the build artifact and use
one of the many different
deployment paradigms
to deploy the artifact.
Everything is fully
automated, and having
every single commit to your
source code management system
built into the artifacts and
then deployed to production.
Some common tools for
continuous deployment
include Puppet, Jenkins,
and bash scripts.
Now that we've gone through
what continuous integration
and continuous
deployment are, you
may be wondering why they're
such important concepts
to apply.
First, they ensure that
all changes to code
are tracked, tested,
and built. Documentation
is key so there are no
questions as to what
features are in each release
and who made the changes.
Second, automating a lot
of these manual tasks
reduces chances of human error.
Going back to the
importance of documentation,
should there be
any sort of bugs,
these will be easily
trackable and you can quickly
roll back to a stable
version to reduce
any outages from deployments.
This leads to increased
innovation and faster time
to market, resulting in happier
deployment, development,
and operations teams.
With CD, oftentimes
teams embrace the concept
of immutable infrastructure.
When delivering an
artifact, you can
rest assured that each
artifact is exactly the same.
After initial deployment,
no additional configuration
is performed on the
VMs and containers,
thus making the fleet
completely standardized.
For VMs, you can use Packer
to automatically perform
this build and versioning.
And for Kubernetes and
containers, you can use Docker.
As a result, you'll get
faster times for launch
to images and
containers as they're
prebaked with all software
and configurations.
In practice, it looks
something like this.
When we have a new binary
or configuration to deploy,
we must first bake
a deployable image
based on a full
build of a server.
Here we install all
runtime dependencies,
such as runtime stacks and, of
course, our application binary.
You can automate this in
any way that you'd like,
such as using Chef,
Puppet, or another tool.
We then deploy this
image as a VM instance
in our various environments
that we test in,
through to production,
where we can
deploy the same image again.
If you're using
Docker containers,
this is a very familiar
territory for you,
and where you can
bake images via docker
build or server-side
build services,
such as Docker Hub and Google
Container Registry build.
If you're deploying
to VMs, Spinnaker
has Packer-based
bakeries that can support
the flow that I just described.
There are other
benefits that are
particularly pertinent as
you're deploying to the cloud.
If your Chef
recipes, for example,
are taking 40
minutes to complete
the build of a
new server, you're
not able to take advantage of
the elasticity of the cloud.
The demand has already
come and passed.
Other ops-critical functions,
such as auto-healing
and rollback images, are
similarly very difficult
if you're not using
these prebaked images.
Another product to highlight
is Google Cloud Deploy.
Google Cloud Deploy allows
users to deliver continuously
to Google Kubernetes Engine,
or GKE, within minutes.
There are many benefits
of this managed service.
First, users don't have to
own, scale, and/or maintain
CD tooling themselves.
Similar to Cloud Build,
Google Cloud Deploy
is a managed service.
This reduces the total
cost of ownership
for continuous delivery.
There are no servers
to manage or patch,
and resources can scale
up and down automatically
to optimize cost
and performance.
It also integrates with Google
Cloud Platform's Identity
and Access Management, and
has audit features built in.
This easily enables
the securing, tracking,
and auditing of delivery
pipelines and related
activities.
Google Cloud
Deploy's opinionation
aims to reduce onboarding
time and cost of ownership
by providing structure to
continuous delivery processes.
You can define releases
and progress them
through environments such as
test, stage, and production,
and there's a one-step
promotion and rollback
of releases via the web
console, CLI, or API.
In addition, there
is built-in support
for metrics to measure and
optimize deployment success.
With increased visibility,
users can gain insights
on deployment metrics and drive
objective-based SRE and DevOps
processes.
This is an example of an
end-to-end CI/CD workflow.
The first step for
a CI/CD pipeline
is to host your code in a
source control management
system, such as Google
Cloud Source Repositories.
Once you upload your
code to your repository,
we'll have to choose from one
of many platforms designed
to facilitate CI/CD.
Many common platforms
were designed
to run all kinds of
automation and have since
been adjusted to support CI/CD.
Google Cloud Build was
designed with CI/CD in mind
and is serverless,
meaning you don't
have to manage the underlying
infrastructure of your builds.
You can configure
Google Cloud Build
with cloudbuild.yaml
files that live directly
in your repository.
Cloud Build facilitates
CI by supporting
many different source control
services, easy integration
with Google Cloud
Services for testing,
and it supports
deploying artifacts
to various destinations,
including Artifact Registry.
Cloud Build supports complex
builds with multiple steps--
for example, testing
and deployments.
If you want to add
to your CI pipeline,
it's as easy as adding
an additional step to it.
Take your artifacts, either
built or stored locally
or at your destination,
and easily deploy it
to one of our many
compute services
with a deployment
strategy of your choice.
VALERIYA SHIN: Now
let's take a look
into how we can create a
deployment pipeline for Cloud
Run that implements
progression of code
from developer branches with
automated canary testing
in Google Cloud Platform.
Cloud Run lets you deploy
and run your applications
with little overhead or effort.
Check out the Cloud Run video in
the description box below just
to get a quick
run-through of Cloud
Run and other compute services
available in Google Cloud
platform.
In this demo, we will create
a sample Cloud Run service,
add a change on a
development branch,
merge the branch into
the mainline branch,
implement canary testing to rule
out any change to the Cloud Run
service.
Let's start off with
preparing our environment.
Let's go to Google
Cloud Console and login
into Google Cloud Project.
In the console, we
activate Cloud Shell.
And now let's create
environmental variables
and enable the needed APIs
if they're not enabled.
And now let's setup the admin
roles for the service account.
If you haven't used git
in Cloud Shell previously,
you can setup a username
and user email values.
And now we will clone and
prepare the sample repository.
We will store the code
from sample repository
in Cloud Service Repositories.
All right.
Now let's move to the
Cloud Run service.
In Cloud Shell, we will build
and deploy the application,
including a service that
requires authentication.
The next step is to enable
a unique URL for development
branches in git.
Each branch is represented
by a URL that's
identified by the branch name.
Commits to the branch
trigger deployment,
and the updates are
accessible at the same URL.
In Cloud Shell, let's
setup a trigger.
Now let's create a new branch
and open the sample application
in the Cloud Shell.
In the sample application,
let's modify the code
to indicate version 1.1
instead of version 1.0.
And now let's commit
the change and push
to the module repository.
You can check the
progress of ongoing
build in the Cloud Build.
Cloud Build can also
trigger a message via email,
Slack, or other
messaging providers.
Now let's get the unique
URL for this branch.
When code is released
to production,
it's common to release code to
a small subset of light traffic
before migrating the traffic
to the new code pages.
Let's implement a trigger
that is activated when code is
committed to the main branch.
The trigger deploys a code
to a unique canary URL
and it routes 10% of all live
traffic to the new version.
All right, let's setup
the branch trigger
and now merge the
branch to the main line
and push to the
module repository.
After the build is complete,
let's review new version.
As you see, 90%
of the traffic is
routed to prod, 10% to canary,
and 0% to the branch revisions.
That brings us to the end
of this video, where we've
been over what is CI/CD,
CI/CD in practice,
setting up CI/CD, deployment
strategies, and a Google Cloud
Console demo.
We have tons of
resources and guides
around setting up CI/CD on
our documentation website.
A couple of resources have been
added in the description box
below to help you
understand these concepts
in further detail.
I encourage you to take a look
prior to setting everything up.
Should you run into any
issues, our support team
is always available, as well.
Stay tuned for all the exciting
content that we have for you.
Don't forget to
like and subscribe
to our YouTube channel.
Click on the bell icon
to get notified each time
a new video is posted.
We'll see you soon in
our next video, where
we will go over different
operations and building
tools in Google Cloud.
Thank you, and
see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]